businesses all across america are
struggling to find workers but they
aren't getting a lot of sympathy for
president biden
check out this exchange with a small
business owner
how do you and the biden administration
plan to incentivize those that haven't
returned to work yet
two things one if you notice we kept you
open and i think it really is
a matter of
people deciding now that they have
opportunities to do other things
and there is a shortage of employees
people are looking
to make more money and and to bargain
and so i think
your business and the tourist business
is really
going to be in a bind for a little while
um
and uh one of the things we're ending
all those things that are
the things keeping people back from from
going back to work etcetera
it'll be interesting to see what happens
but it was so nice of him to say we kept
you open
wasn't that pleasant yo dagan it's kind
of weird that
i am a small business owner that i know
more about economics than an 80 year old
president of the united states
if you pay more people you're gonna have
to raise all the salaries and then
you're gonna have to start letting go
workers so you can afford the higher
salaries or you
increase the price of your product which
then increases inflation
and that's what you're going to see did
i just explain economics 101 i think i
deserve a nobel prize so i have a
10-page article from the wall street
journal that i plan to read
the entirety of it out loud in this
segment about how much
the goods that um are going up in price
that companies are having to raise all
these prices
inflation's clearly become a huge issue
for the white house but
joe biden keeps coming out and saying
we're going to spend more money so
that's going to help inflation
and actually people's wages when
adjusted for inflation
are going down they're down in the most
recent month and they're down over the
last year
but that whole i that is the one thing
that i wrote down
we kept you open oh he's such a
benevolent
king and that business owner is just
some plebe
that is the thinking of somebody who has
been in politics
for five decades it's awful screw that
yeah it's definitely it's it's only
something jessica
a democrat would say because democrat
believes that
the power of big government and
the that that trumps
anything like small business meanwhile
who made a lot of money
in the during uh because of biden big
business
all the small businesses are fake should
he be impeached yeah
that's tomorrow's show okay i already
got the topic list
um no he shouldn't be impeached i
so his answer was actually he talked for
two and a half minutes
in biden's style and there were actually
a style a lot of like gangnam style
but it's one long palindrome but there
was actually a lot of sentimentality to
it he talked about how his father-in-law
of his deceased wife was a restaurant
owner up in syracuse and desperately
wanted him to stay to take over the
business and he said like god love you
for what you do
i also want to point out not that it
doesn't mean that small businesses
aren't struggling that gentleman who
asked the question owns 39 restaurants
it's not a mom-and-pop shop on the
corner people have been getting wiped
out by amazon for years right
it's a different kind of thing the
inflation issue is definitely
becoming a polling nightmare for
democrats because people
are their groceries cost more i've seen
a lot online um bethenny mandel has been
tweeting about the price of diapers she
just had
i think her fifth child last week and
she's like oh my god i've only taken
a year and a half out of this game and
the price is so absorbent and these are
things people
need and if that continues into an
election
you are going to have a problem and he
said we have an economist
with several who are saying that this is
temporary that is my hope
but there definitely needs to be a
backup plan to this if
it isn't something that's temporary and
you want to stay in power
did you just cite a real housewife
bethany mandel
is she a real householder
bethany frankel i think she's a
wonderful writer
and she has five children and she's a
stay-at-home mother
oh chef mandel's wife i don't know who
these people are she is the women of the
person who knows a lot about a lot of
things
what about the price of diapers because
you got a baby
you got a baby he doesn't know anything
about those prices i look at other
prices but they're probably up
he lied out of the gate he said we kept
you open biden's party kept restaurants
closed
not only last year but into this year
and that was a trump program
that bailed out those restaurants not
him
and then to say that you know we kept
you open democrat governors were
arresting restaurant owners
who tried to open and fining them and
then you spelled it out perfectly that's
why we had the 200
fries gut felt because you're competing
with the federal government's 300
fake bonus so you have to raise wages
you have small profit margins
pass it on to the customer raise prices
that's why things are so expensive
and then he said the funniest thing he
said spending six trillion dollars
will not increase inflation it will
decrease inflation
and then he cited moody's now never
listen to moody's you know this
moody's is a left-wing operation mark
zandy is a left-wing guy
donates to the clintons donates to all
democrats he predicted that trump was
going to sink the economy into a
recession
in 2018 and destroy three and a half
million jobs and predicted barack
obama's recovery was going to be the
hottest on record so never listen to a
democrat when they cite moody's
there you go that's a warning katie it
seems to me that the biden
administration cares more about the woke
than the work i think that's true i
think that was
that was a good one greg someone who
grew up in a small business
the responses like this from politicians
who have been
getting paychecks from taxpayers signing
the back of them rather than signing the
front of them
their entire lives for 30 40 years is
really enraging and when you look at the
way that the bind administration is
importing
millions of people aka cheap foreign
labor which obviously
suppresses the wages of american workers
at a time when people should be going
back to work
and then you had today jen saki saying
that it's a
workers market well why is it a workers
market you would think that after a
pandemic when a lot of people lost their
jobs people will be clamoring to get
back to work to get back into the labor
force
instead they're competing with the
federal government who is paying
paying people with hard-earned taxpayer
dollars not to go back to work and then
they have the nerve to say
you need to pay 15 an hour no matter
which city you live in
no matter what economic situation your
town may be in
it's just such a naive elitist argument
to make
and the government can afford this right
but the people that the government is
competing against can't
there's something you should just raise
your prices that's what we're doing
ridiculous
but that policy is ending and he cited
that that was something that he did
he admitted it finally so forever the
white house was saying this has no
impact on people going back to work the
unemployment and then biden admits
finally yesterday that
yeah we're ending those programs because
it's preventing people from going back
except
all these new entitlements he wants to
push through are not based on work
right you can collect them with no work
requirement my parents were small
business owners
and you get screwed by the government
over and over again that's why i said
screw that
all right now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else